So far, we've established that fundamentally,...
...PR aims to create understanding between different parties.
Today, modern mass media is everywhere.
Interest and pressure groups in politics and business are all around us.
This means that the ability to influence public opinion...
...and behavior is critical to the survival of organizations.
This is particularly true for organizations seeking public attention, government support,...
...funding or credibility in the community.
Public relations plays a key role in developing, understanding...
...and defining relationships between the different parties.
It narrows the gap between an organization's perception of itself and how others perceive it.
Communication plays a vital role in PR.
PR practitioners use a variety of communication techniques to communicate with their publics.
One of these is advertising, which is sometimes confused with PR.
With advertising, the sponsor controls the words used,...
...where and how often the advertisement is placed, and the cost.
Advertising is limited specifically to products and services and brands,...
...with the goal of generating sales.
PR is much broader than advertising.
Of course, publicity is a central aspect of PR.
Publicity, in its broadest sense, refers to exposure in any public media of individuals,...
...organizations, services or products.
It can be positive or negative.
Publicity is often used in PR, but in a more limited and defined sense.
It refers to information communicated in the media, as news or items of public interest.
In most cases, these are not paid for.
Publicity, in a PR sense, is mainly about independent editorial coverage.
The recipient of this publicity often has no, or very little control...
...over the content and where or when it is received.